[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 14 avril voici
les titres j - 10 avant le deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle les
soutiens du président candidat emmanuel
macron viennent faire campagne dans les
yvelines hier agnès pannier rue nash
était présente à saint rémy les
chevreuse la ministre délégué à
l'industrie est venu échanger sur
l'indépendance énergétique en plein
contexte de la guerre en ukraine une
mystérieuse pollution de la senne hier
une nappe blanche à traiter à
perceptible sur le fleuve entre ben
cours et méricourt les équipes
spécialisées dans les risques chimiques
des pompiers des yvelines ont été
mobilisés interview dans cette édition
et puis mieux gérer l'eau sur les golfs
de l'hexagone c'est la volonté de la
fédération française de la discipline un
partenariat avec l'agencé de l'eau seine
normandie a été signée cette semaine au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
il est d'ailleurs à ce sujet tout à
l'heure philippe pilato sera notre
invité les le directeur du golf national
de saint quentin en hiver
[Musique]
on débute donc ce journal par cette
réunion publique hier mercredi à saint
rémy les chevreuse comme tous les mois
le député jean noël barrot organise des
temps d'échangés avec les habitants
cette fois ci il était accompagnée
d'agnès panier rue nash ministre délégué
à l'industrie venus parler
d'indépendance énergétique un rendez
vous forcément particulier avec la
guerre en ukraine en ce moment et dans
un contexte d'entre deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle céline charles
etc diaga tsongor vers une indépendance
énergétique et industriel c'était le
thème de la réunion publique organisée
ce mercredi par jean noël barrot à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse la ministre
délégué chargé de l'industrie agnès
pannier rue nash et est venu répondre
aux questions des habitants
le thème me plaît bien surtout en ce
moment avec eux de ce qui se passe c'est
que le cren on n'a pas du tout exploité
encore les autres énergies en europe qui
sont très courants dans les autres pays
notamment la méthanisation
le solaire un échange sur des thèmes
importants qui préoccupe de plus en plus
les français l'enjeu c'est de développer
de nouvelles formes de chauffage et de
moteurs pour se déplacer qu'ils
n'utilisent pas les matières les
énergies fossiles c'est à dire de
continuer à développer du nucléaire de
continuer à développer des énergies
renouvelables notamment le
photovoltaïque et l'éolien marin et de
miser beaucoup sur la sobriété
écologique plan de relance programme
territoire d'industrie transition
écologique et création d'emplois la
réunion fut l'occasion de revenir sur le
mandat d' emmanuel macron et de se
projeter vers l'avenir dans cette phase
importante d'entre deux tours on va
essayer de passer ces onze jours qui
nous restent jusqu'au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
à tendre la main à toutes celles et ceux
qui veulent
choisir un
une france de l'avenir plutôt qu'une
france de l'impasse c'est à dire le
choix de la candidate de l'extrême
droite ça suppose évidemment de se
rassembler très largement de tendre la
main aux électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
aux électeurs de yannick jadot d'anne
hidalgo mais aussi de valérie pécresse
une réunion qui permet d'écouter et de
parler très concrètement aux personnes
qui auront à faire un choix crucial le
24 avril prochain
et on attend dans ce deuxième tour tv 78
vous aide à y voir plus clair sur le
rôle de président de la république c'est
avec raphaël mata duvignau professeur de
droit public à l'université versailles
saint quentin et membre du collectif des
surligneurs ce soir décryptage des
relations du chef de l'état avec les
autres institutions publiques de la vème
république la vème république est un
régime politique particulier dans le
sens où nous présente la république
dispose de prérogatives importantes
vis-à-vis des autres institutions tout
d'abord il désigne le pré ministre et
sur proposition de ce dernier les
ministres mais le gouvernement n'est pas
responsable devant le président ce
dernier ne pouvant pas juridiquement les
renvoyer ou les démettre de leurs
fonctions toutefois dans les faits la
pratique est différente surtout si les
tendances politiques sont les mêmes
selon la constitution c'est bien le
gouvernement qui détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation mais lorsque les
majorités présidentielles et
parlementaires sont identiques c'est
bien le chef de l'état qui décide des
grandes orientations et le gouvernement
ne fait que les appliquer et les mettre
en oeuvre le présent peut également
prononcer la dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale ce qui lui permet de résoudre
une crise politique ou un blocage
institutionnel comme ce fut le cas avec
de gaulle ou mitterrand le président
peut être également adressé des messages
à l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat et
il peut surtout depuis 2008 prendre la
parole directement devant le parlement
réuni en congrès à versailles
vis-à-vis de l'autorité judiciaire le
président nomme les magistrats
professionnels mais surtout les
magistrats du parquet qui sont chargés
de mettre en oeuvre et d'appliquer la
politique pénale du gouvernement
le président nomme également trois
membres du conseil constitutionnel mais
surtout il a la possibilité de le saisir
afin que ce dernier vérifie la
conformité d'une loi ou d'un traité à la
constitution manifestant ainsi son rôle
de gardien de la norme suprême et de
l'indépendance nationale il doit
également le consulter s'il envisage de
mettre en oeuvre les pouvoirs de crise
et enfin à l'issue de son mandat le
président devient membre de droit à vis
du conseil constitutionnel
enfin le président de la république
détient une prog hâtive importante
vis-à-vis du peuple une recours au
référendum alors au final si le
président de la république dispose de
mon action important sur les autres
pouvoirs leur utilisation dépend en
réalité non seulement de la personnalité
de leurs titulaires mais aussi de la
configuration politique
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité un policier
condamné à six mois de prison avec
sursis cet ex agent de la brigade
anticriminalité reconnu coupable par le
tribunal correctionnel de versailles de
violence des faits remontant à 2015 à
chanteloup-les-vignes survenu lors d'une
interpellation musclée dans le quartier
de la noé une vidéo montre le policier
assénant un coup de poing à un individu
menotté avant de tirer au flashball vers
un passant en revanche l'agent n'a pas
l'interdiction d'exercer ses fonctions
il officie aujourd'hui au sein de la br
i trois de ses collègues sont heureux
l'axé poursuivi pour faux et usage de
faux en écriture publique pour avoir
rédigé un procès verbal incomplet lors
de cette intervention la mobilisation
des enseignants des trois collèges de
trappes ce jeudi à 18h les professeurs
de yoyo et de youri gagarine de gustave
courbet et du village se sont réunis
devant les locaux de l'inspection
académique à guyancourt une
manifestation soutenue par la ville de
trappes et qui était aux côtés de ses
fonctionnaires ce jeudi soit le motif de
cette mobilisation dénoncer les moyens
horaires attribués aux trois
établissements pour la rentrée prochaine
les enseignants craignent des classes
surchargées deux journées de grève avait
déjà eu lieu en mars attrape une nappe
blanche et visqueuse qui est apparu sur
la scène ce mercredi au niveau 2
bennecourt et méricourt à un rejet
ponctuelle est très attendue sur une
quinzaine de kilomètres et les services
de secours dont une vingtaine de
pompiers ont été mobilisés pour
identifier l'origine de cette pollution
est tenté de l'éliminer ont fait le
point avec le capitaine rémi échoue
levitte conseiller
nick risque chimique des pompiers des
yvelines qui a été interrogée par
mélanie poker
autres centres opérationnels a reçu un
appel qui mettait en évidence une
pollution sur le lit de la scène aucune
pollution avec un reflet blanchâtre
disparates
le centre opérationnel à mobiliser des
moyens de reconnaissance terrestre
également une embarcation s'est depuis
la scène une équipe spécialisée presque
chimiques et des pollutions nos
opérations d'abord
on était orientée sur la recherche
justement de ce point d'origine voici le
caractériser cette pollution dont
comprendre le phénomène et de m ensuite
ça des actions en place
[Musique]
14 km c'est extrêmement grand puisque en
termes de pollution notre notre action
pour aussi de protéger l'environnement
consiste à essayer de canaliser le
paiement pour le récupérer l'eau pompée
or là contre la longueur
de l'étendue c'est un peu louche on
puisque je veux certainement ses
pulsions bien avant son notre alerte
qui nous était impossible de la
canaliser la récupérer
[Musique]
vingt-quatre heures après
malheureusement le courant de la semaine
a déporté à cette pollution
nous avions alerté précocément les
services partenaires et les services de
secours du val d'oise et de leurs les
éléments factuels pour l'audace et déjà
l'absence de toxicité de l'environnement
c'est à dire à proximité puis ce qu'on
appelle une détection avec nos appareils
et d un mois d'absence des mortalités
piscicoles qui est un signe favorable
car ensuite ce sont les analyses a
transmise par la gendarmerie nationale
qui permettront de définir à la qualité
c'est triste et pour l'environnement
il convenait on attend de ses résultats
de formuler des préconisations à la fin
pour la population et puis également de
rassurer les habitants sur le fait que
l'eau potable n'était pas concerné par
cette pollution
[Musique]
c'était dans les cartons depuis deux ans
c'est désormais confirmé le cimentier
calcia abandonne définitivement son
projet de carrière de calcaire dans le
parc naturel régional du vexin
l'information est rapportée par nos
confrères du parisien citant une source
proche de la direction la fin donc d'un
projet vieux de plusieurs décennies qui
avait pourtant obtenu toutes les
autorisations nécessaires plusieurs
recours d'associations environnementales
et d'élus avaient été rejetées par la
justice le dernier en date du 1er avril
débouté par le tribunal administratif de
versailles
direction à présent le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette semaine
la fédération de golf la fédération
française de golf a signé un partenariat
avec l'agencé de l'eau seine normandie
pour mieux gérer l'eau sur les parcours
un axe important pour la ffg qui a déjà
investi 12 millions d'euros dans des
systèmes d'irrigation les précisions de
michael et demi d'euros et demi de
mathilde frank ou
le golf veut continuer sa transition
écologique ce mardi 12 avril la
fédération française a signé un
partenariat avec l'agencé de l'eau seine
normandie au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines objectif mieux gérer
la gestion de l'eau sur et autour des
greens les travaux notamment nécessaire
dans certains golfs construit dans les
années 80 les systèmes aujourd'hui sont
bien évidemment plus performants qui à
30 ans mais en prenant les bonnes
décisions qui n'étaient pas forcément
qu'ils étaient les bonnes décisions 10 à
30 ans il ya trente ans on pouvait
arrosé l'erreur on pouvait arroser des
zones qui n'étaient pas des zones
indispensables aujourd'hui si on veut
préserver les ressources en eau il faut
faire des choix et quand vous arrivez à
cumuler ces deux intérêts qui sont de 1
mieux arroser certains espaces que vous
choisissez avec un matériel plus
performant et bien on arrive tout de
suite à des économies en termes d'eau
d'utilisation d'eau et c'est ce qu'on
recherche à travers cette convention
entre autres cette convention prévoit
des objectifs chiffrés sur les trois
prochaines années et des axes de travail
dans 163 golf présents sur le bassin
seine et normandie donc l'objectif c'est
de réduire de 30 % la quantité de
produits samy une phytosanitaires
utilisés sur les golfs du bassin il ya
des objectifs en termes d'économies de
aussi 250 mille mètres cubes d'eau
seront économisés sur les trois ans de
la convention grâce à des
investissements qui permettent à une
irrigation plus contrôlés plus maîtrisée
nous avons aussi des objectifs en termes
de désintermédiation ce qu'on appelle la
d imperméabilisation dont permettre à
l'eau de s'infiltrer jusqu'en 2024
lagence peut aider les golfs et dans
leur transition écologique en apportant
entre 40 et 60 % des aides pour investir
dans le matériel la structure peut
également financer des études préalables
aux investissements entre 50 et 70%
[Musique]
et pour continuer à parler de ce sujet
philippe pilato est avec nous un plateau
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un lieu qu'on
ne présente plus théâtre de la ryder cup
en 2018 de grands événements à venir
aussi cette année dont on va parler dans
un instant le golf national ces trois
parcours près de 140 hectares pour le
site saint quentinois parler de
transition écologique pour un tel lieu
ça devient incontournable c'est un sujet
qu'on ne peut pas éluder aujourd'hui bas
la transition écologique effectivement
c'est demain à celles à venir et c'est
vrai que sur un site comme les notes
site de la fédération française de golf
avec les engagements de la fédération
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous
échangeons mais pratiquement deux façons
de façon quotidienne et c'est vrai qu'il
faut qu'on apprenne demain qu'on
anticipe demain et on se doit d'être
d'être d'être devant de la scène par
rapport à ça oui tout à fait y avait
déjà une vigilance avant la signature ce
partenariat sur ces questions
écologiques oui bien sûr mais bien
évidemment mais on en est très
très à cheval là dessus par rapport à la
signature pour l'os est effectivement de
l'eau c'est la vie l'eau c'est demain
donc mon à des restrictions 1 qui sont
et qui sont et qui sont actives être ton
de l'année donc ça va certainement
arriver cette année en saison sur
lesquels on est très vigilant sur les
hommes sur lesquels on en capacité de da
ros et l'homme n'a osé mais ce qui est
important de faire c'est c'est
d'anticiper demain c'est d'anticiper
mais les restrictions qui seront
peut-être de plus en plus nombreuses et
de réfléchir à comment est-ce qu'on peut
être en capacité de toujours arroser les
zones de jeu de façon intelligente et de
façon à minimiser justement
l'utilisation d'eau laurie on l'a
entendue dans le sujet le partenariat
entre la fédération française de golf et
l'agencé de l'eau seine normandie fixe
plusieurs objectifs réduire de 30% l
utilisation de produits phytosanitaires
économiser deux cent cinquante mille
mètres cubes d'eau et aussi des actions
à mettre en place pour la perméabilité
des sols comment ça va se traduire pour
le golf national s'il ya déjà des
objectifs fixés on a déjà à l'heure en
termes d'objectifs on n'a pas
d'objectifs quantifiés mais on a déjà
effectué des travaux dans le cas de la
ryder cup en 2018 qui nous ont permis
justement mais d'optimiser la l'arrosage
ans puisqu'on parle de l'eau
donc de façon à arroser intelligemment
d'arroser les bonnes surface de jeu
arrosé un green c'est un exemple un peu
tout bête mais on est un green on plante
on a heureusement pas la même quantité
d'eau sur la route de sueur sur le sur
la partie haute du green que sur la
partie basse donc on a vraiment
anticiper tout cela après derrière
effectivement pour tout ce qui est
produits phytosanitaires c'était un
sujet sur lequel on est vraiment très
vigilant on a un parcours en alpha
recours l'albatros et le parcours de
l'aigle qui est un deuxième parcours et
sur lequel on est pratiquement on est
très vertueux et sur lequel on fait on
fait on fait beaucoup d'opérations
mécanique qui justement elles permettent
de minimiser l'utilisation d'intrants 8
août est-ce que deux prochains
investissements sont prévus dont la
matière m brice concernant l'eau il faut
qu'on réfléchisse par rapport à ça et
effectivement il faut qu'on réfléchisse
à savoir est-ce qu'on peut être en
capacité de tourner en circuit en
circuit fermé enfin bon il ya tout un
tas de sujets sur lesquels on travaille
et des sujets qui leur ont embouties
henry --l'agence et de l'oim disait dans
le reportage qu'elle pourrait aussi
aider les golfs sur ses investissements
alors le golf national revit aussi peu à
peu il faut le dire après différents
confinement la pratique du golf ne s'est
jamais réellement arrêté on peut dire
même que le golf a profité de cette peur
il ya une progression du nombre de
licenciés +4 32% mais les événements
dessous n'ont pas pu forcément se tenir
crise sanitaire oblige alors il ya le
retour des événements peu à peu dans ce
golf national lui la nationale golfweek
début avril sous la neige même mais il
ya eu cet événement d'autres événements
vont arriver c'est une grande joie on
imagine de retrouver de la vie peu à peu
sur ce golf national oui mais comme je
le dis souvent on est un peu on est un
peu dopé à l'événement sur le site web
national et quand on a goûté tous les
open de france championnats du monde
amateurs qu'on avait cueilli en 94 et
championnat france des jeunes enfin
voilà on est en héros on nourrit à cela
et c'est vrai que les équipes qui sont
sur site si on arrive à les fidéliser
c'est parce que on est en capacité
justement de pouvoir accueillir ce type
d'événements qui sont des coupures dans
l'année qui sont des objectifs donc ça
aussi c'est très bien parce que en
termes de management ça permet de fixer
des objectifs des objectifs concrets et
de mener à bien les équipes verts vera
vers ces objectifs là oui tout à fait
lors de grands événements qui vont
arriver on pense forcément à ces jeux
olympiques c'est un peu plus tard en
2024 me a déjà les championnats du monde
amateurs par équipe picarde par équipes
qui vont se tenir au golf national et
aussi au golf de saint nom la bretèche
et du 24 août au 3 septembre là on
pourra voir les futures grandes stars du
golf ne peut le dire ah oui non mais
c'est sur serre que quand on fait quand
on regarde les joueurs qui ont joué les
précédents championnats du monde
amateurs bon nous on a eu la chance sur
le site du hac nationale en 1994
d'accueillir tailleur outré que nos
jouets bon on a vu sa carrière qui remue
après la ryder cup et qui enseigne à la
laideur cup en 2018 omnia john ram qui a
participé et justin thomas et qui a
morikawa enfin tous les tous les joueurs
qui sont là et qui sont présents la
maintenance à très haut niveau qui
gagnent des tournois des majeures ainsi
de suite ont participé ont participé à
ces championnats donc on verra forcément
les champions de demain sur le site du
off nationale oui d'ailleurs un troupeau
de futures pépites à préciser on l'a on
en a pas les sur tv 78 que le golf
national accueille désormais on peut le
dire le le clairefontaine du golfe avec
des jeunes qui vont pouvoir suivre une
scolarité adaptée pour suivre leur
formation en golf 27 professeurs et
aussi des installations dernier cri et
je le disais on le qualifie de
clairefontaine du golfe forcément
référence aux clairefontaine du football
qui est déjà présent dans les yvelines à
un dernier événement qui est attendu
avec impatience et aussi l'open de
france qui fait son retour au golf
national après deux années d'absence
paris c'est la crise sanitaire aussi qui
a forcé l'annulation des deux dernières
éditions une nouvelle date aussi du 22
au 25 septembre avec une dotation qui a
été doublé 3 millions d'euros il y aura
des des golfeurs de renoncer c'est
l'objectif à la fédération travaille
pour ça bien sûr bien sûr ce qui fait la
qualité d'un tournoi il ya bien sûr la
dotation mais il ya le champ des joueurs
la qualité des chants des joueurs donc
la chance que nous avons c'est que le
parcours de l'albatros est un parcours
qui est plébiscité par les joueurs qui a
adoré par les joueurs il aime ce
parcours parce que c'est un parcours
très sélectif et killian l'open de
france s'il gagne pas par hasard c'est à
dire c'est c'est une semaine sur
laquelle il faut entre en forme et
l'open de france se mérite donc
effectivement on travaille là dessus la
chance que nous avons c'est que sur
cette semaine là me lie à ce que la
présidente cap qui qui en fait
rassembler meilleurs joueurs américains
contre les meilleurs joueurs du reste du
monde donc on peut espérer que les
meilleurs joueurs européens et en est
qui n'ont pas de tournoi on va dire à
important à jouer sur cette semaine là
puissent venir jouer au golf national
oui qu'on espère une est au rendez vous
on se rappelle en 2018 c'était à peu
près sur les mêmes périodes la ryder cup
il y avait eu un temps superbe au golf
national c'était le printemps oui tout à
fait très longtemps donc ça se prépare
comment ça se prépare justement ce genre
d'événement mais on y est là on est en
plein dedans
on commence déjà à cette semaine on est
en train de faire des opérations ce
qu'on appelle d'aération et de sablage
des du parcours et donc on ne fait pas
que les greens acr qu'on fait on part de
derrière départ on fait les départs ont
fait l'effet rayons frais les prix green
et les greens donc ça ce sont des
opérations qui ont fait de façon à faire
en sorte à ce que les joueurs puissent
avoir des conditions de jeu optimales à
une ferme avec des graines qui roulent
avec des surfaces de jeu lorsqu'ils sont
sur les ferries qui sont également ferme
donc on travaille déjà donc là là ça
fait ça on a 7 jours de fermeture pour
cet événement et après petit à petit on
va faire des opérations chaque semaine
qui vont faire en sorte à ce que le
parcours monte en puissance monte en
puissance et soit de façon préparé de
façon exceptionnelle pour les
championnats du monde amateurs parce que
quinze jours après en soi l'open de
france ce qui veut dire que globalement
pour le casot open de france le parcours
devrait être incroyable de grandes
échéances à venir cette année pour le
golf national merci philippe pilate oh
merci d'être venu en parler sur ce
plateau sera le mail que vous êtes le
directeur du golf national installé à
saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
on reste au golf mais du côté du golf de
bêtement à poissy jusqu'à dimanche
l'association art gold propose de
découvrir l'exposition l'art sur les ti
et deux objectifs rendre l'art
accessible et inciter les femmes à
pratiquer la discipline le reportage de
justin brasier
l'art sur les ti une exposition d'art
contemporain installée dans un golf
c'est ce que vous propose l'association
art egolf sur le site de bêtement à
poissy une première édition pour faire
se rencontrer ce sport et l'art à
l'origine du projet il ya ma passion
dans lequel j'ai envie de te voilà de
continuer à évoluer
et je suis aussi très sensible à l'art
sous toutes ses formes et donc j'ai eu
l'idée et nous envie de réunir ces deux
discipline
nos patients deux objectifs rendre l'art
accessible aux habitants de la grande
couronne et attirer les femmes vers la
discipline elles sont moitié moins
nombreuses à la pratiquer pour ce faire
à côté en plus de l'exposition des
initiations golfique sont proposés aux
visiteurs pour gratuit c'est ouvert il
suffit de réserver et on a deux heures
une initiation au golf alors où ça plaît
et tant mieux on qu'on accroche et en
continu ou pas mais ça aurait été une
belle expérience fait revenir l'art sur
un lieu autre qu un lieu d'exposition
classique une idée qui a séduit les
artistes ils sont seize à participer à
cette initiative le golf c'est vraiment
quelque chose que je ne connaissais pas
a comme je connais le lard quoi le voilà
donc c'est déjà trouvé le lien très bien
si ça pouvait marcher aussi dans l'autre
sens que les personnes qui sont plus
habitués au golfe viennent regarder
il ya des golfeurs il ya des artistes
qui viennent voir les sculptures et nous
mêmes on à l'intéressé on va aller faire
un petit tour sur le parcours c'est une
belle association quand on est parti sur
un parcours on a un peu les étapes d et
c'est un peu comme dans la sculpture de
la réalisation d'une sculpture c'est des
états c'est un objectif sur place une
quarantaine d'oeuvres sont exposées
jusqu'au dimanche 17 avril initiation et
compétition sur inscription plus
d'informations sur le site du golf
et puis avant de refermer ce journal la
sélection officielle du festival de
cannes a été dévoilée ce jeudi parmi les
films programmés en séance de minuit que
de minuit fumer fait tousser de quentin
dupieux au casting plusieurs yvelinois
jérôme niel et les humoristes du
palmashow grégoire ludig et david
marsais qui ont déjà joué récemment pour
quentin dupieux dans mandibules à
l'affiché également gilles lellouche
vincent lacoste anaïs dumoustiers ou
encore adel ex art show poulos le 75e
festival de cannes se déroulera du 17 au
28 mai prochain voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité demain
vendredi vous avez rendez vous avec le
7-8 week-end actualité et idées de
sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]